[Musique]
je m'excuse je choisirais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est dingue ça parce que moi aussi je
te déteste c'est quand tu vois parce que
moi je t'aime tu m'aimes
farid oui je t'aime
[Musique]
vous êtes vous êtes là pour comme sur
homicide de monsieur homicide on va
super nous avons un hiver on y va on y
va aller avec moi aux volontaires c'est
pas grave
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce truc massacré calmement
les gens comme ça pas l'impression
petite batterie on avait l'impression
que tu as rangé ton bureau le temps les
regarde cette encore du sang plein la
bouche ça monsieur par van buyten
parfaitement même ça fait 80 euros soit
pas m'emmerder pour trois paires de
boeufs ou lourd un sac à main mais ces
salles excuse j'ai fait 80 objets droit
de crever les yeux de pauvre type dans
la rue te voir péter les dents de brûler
les yeux qui gamine de scalper des
vigiles son trottoir nommé d'une
rencontre c'est une règle de cela
[Musique]
je me rendais chez ma mère je me suis
trompé d'étagé lorsqu'ils montrent
ouverts des propriétaires des lieux
lançant une mise en scène et m'ont forcé
à passer cette tenue les objets trouvés
sur moi et dans moi ne m'appartiennent
pas ceci est un simple malentendu
c'est ça tout à fait ok mon père aussi
né là alléluia je peux pas vous serrez
plus sa chanson monsieur il faut juste
pas